to the queen of country music Dolly
Parton of course and we joined the 70
year old legend in Nashville today to
celebrate a major milestone 50 years and
show business makes you feel proud makes
you feel old but it makes you feel like
you might have done something good in
your lives just being a part of country
music after all these years I've been
here a long time et has been with dolly
for a lot of those 50 years in the
spotlight
I will never retire I like the work she
says she's never slowing down and you
know somebody's magic when fans like
Reese Witherspoon and Katy Perry
idolized her hi everyone what the
Hollywood pull with Dolly Parton I've
seen her a few times and I'm very
touched by all these gals it's a I've
touched them or inspired them and makes
me feel like I might have done something
right and hopefully I can give them you
know you know tricks of the trade if
they ask me I always say don't give
advice but he wants some information I
can deliver that left
17
Dali's also celebrating five decades of
marriage with husband Karl Dean who is
rarely photographed
Dulli set up a photo shoot for their
50th anniversary we were going to sell
them if we made enough money for charity
we were gonna you know donate the money
to children's charities but we didn't
get any big big offers not enough for me
to expose Karl after all these years off
and then if somebody still wants to buy
them on our first anniversary we'll will
sell them for the right price it has to
be over a million let's put it that way
her movie Dolly Parton's Christmas of
many colors circle of love airs November
the 30th on NBC and we love she can
laugh at herself she read this mean
tweet last night on Jimmy Kimmel it's
not a hooker convention it's a Dolly
Parton concert I think Jimmy's funny I
don't care what they say about me I used
to make more fun of myself than anybody
can make of me
you